>>Katherine: How often do
you use a device like this,
as opposed to the mountain tops
when there's an emergency situation?
>>Emergencies that happen outside of
our range of coverage right now, we--
>>Narrator: Every Tuesday
and Thursday afternoon,
High Tech High junior
Katie Anderson reports
in at San Diego police
headquarters for her internship.
>>So would this work
in a moving vehicle?
>>Yes, it would, as long as
you're within line of sight
and the antennas are near a window.
>>Narrator: Anderson is working
with the public safety department
to improve communications
with helicopter pilots
flying emergency missions,
like tracking carjackers
and fighting wildfires.
>>Katherine: So it's just two passes.
It's this one, and
then you do it again,
but it's bumped twenty two
point five degrees to--
>>Sara: Right, What I care
about are these holes.
>>Hi Katie, I've got
something for you.
>>Narrator: Working with adults
in real world settings is a core
design principle of High Tech High.
>>The academic internship program
is a program that each and every one
of our students has the
opportunity to participate in.
In fact, it's a graduation
requirement.
We send about a hundred and
fifty students per semester
out into a real wide
variety of internship sites,
and in a wide variety of industries.
>>Sara: The golden
rule is this bridge.
>>Stacey: It provides them
the opportunity to develop
and foster relationships with adults
that typically eleventh graders
don't have the opportunity to do.
>>And so there are some
challenges out there.
>>Katherine: Okay.
>>So we look at your plan and
come up with a different solution.
>>Stacey: Because High Tech
High is a project based school,
we really take our
internships to the next level.
We train our mentors and we push them
to really empower our
eleventh grade students to work
on meaningful projects
for their organization.
>>Katherine: I mean, how often
does it bounce off the geography
in the right way?
Because most of the time, our
helicopters are below the receivers.
>>Narrator: The internships
include a two week immersion period
in the middle of the semester.
>>Katherine: This is the first
year that they're having immersion,
so I'm here nine to four
for two weeks and I think
that it's really great as well.
It gives me a chance
to get a lot done.
>>Narrator: For the
rest of the semester,
Katie spends two afternoons
a week on site.
>>Sara: Now what do you think about
his concept of flying two heights?
>>Katherine: I don't like it
because they'll just be hovering
between a thousand feet and a little
above five hundred feet, right?
>>From the very first day we
started taking her to meetings,
she's asked great questions.
She understands the engineering
and the science behind
what we're trying to do.
>>Katherine: So if you're mountain
top is here, then this would be--
this is an aerial view, but
this would be your normal bubble
of coverage.
And I'm trying to figure
out where bubbles are,
where there wouldn't be coverage--
>>Sara: It's not like we're
having to explain physics to her.
She already knows a lot of
that, and what she doesn't know,
she goes on the internet
and researches.
>>But then Hugh is also putting
in what's called a quad receiver,
which can be angled, so you
get something like this.
So he wants to know the
range of that as well.
>>Sara: We're getting a lot
out of this, and her project is
to build a map that will be used
by every public safety
agency in the county.
In the end, when the big one breaks
out, the next natural disaster
or fire, we're going to
go to the map Katie made.
So it's gonna be a valuable
project for years to come.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org